Готель "Венеція" на околиці Києва.
Звичайним туристам сюди не потрапити.
За муром з колючим дротом - пансіонат для клієнтів клініки BioTexCom.
Найбільшого центру сурогатного материнства в Україні.
Клієнти клініки - бездітні пари з усього світу.
Серед них - і ці німці. На інтерв'ю вони погодились лише на умовах анонімності.
Не хочуть бути впізнаними вдома в Німеччині, де сурогатне материнство заборонене.
Ми понад дев'ять років мріяли про дитину. Проте нічого не виходило.
У мене сталося кілька викиднів.
Тож ми зважилися на те, щоб нашу генетичну дитину виносила сурогатна мати.
Це дивовижне відчуття. Ми щасливі, що у нас нарешті є власна дитина.
Ми дивимось на неї 24 години на добу. Це такі емоції.
Ми просто закохані в неї і досі не можемо повірити.
Ця німецька пара - одні з небагатьох дорослих гостей готелю "Венеція".
Вони встигли прилетіти в Україну буквально за день до закриття кордонів у середині березня
- за два місяці до народження доньки.
Крім їхньої дитини в готелі - десятки немовлят, яких українки виносили
і народили для іноземців.
Більшість із них батьки можуть побачити лише на фотографіях і відео,
які їм надсилає персонал.
Сподіваюсь, що цим батькам допоможуть, що ці діти нарешті побачать своїх батьків.
Це моє найбільше бажання. У мене розривається серце.
Я гадаю, що деякі батьки роками чекали на дитину.
А перші тижні такі важливі для зв'язку мами з малям.
Якщо ситуація не зміниться, посольство допоможе нам знайти рейс
і ми полетимо назад.
Є спеціальні чартерні рейси. Дійсно, єдина проблема зараз - це приїхати сюди.
Розголосу ситуація набула після того, як клініка BioTexCom оприлюднила відео з малюками,
яких не можуть забрати батьки.
Щоб потрапити до своїх дітей, вони через посольства мають отримати дозвіл МЗС України.
Також можна звернутись до уповноваженої з прав людини.
Але багато батьків про це просто не знають.
Тож бюрократичний процес триває тижні. А інколи - місяці.
Тим часом у сурогатних матерів ледь не щодня народжуються нові діти.
Скільки їх нині в Україні, достеменно не знає ніхто.
Деякі перебувають в орендованих квартирах, а доглядає за ними
не медичний персонал, а бебіситери.
У цей час було важко знайти кваліфікований персонал і, відповідно, догляд був різний.
Умови у всіх різні - все залежить від агенції.
Медичні заклади та клініки репродуктивної медицини,
які мали можливість забезпечити медичний догляд,
пропонували такі умови, але інколи це було занадто дорого для батьків.
Це ж додаткові витрати. Адже в Україну їдуть здебільшого ті пари,
бюджет яких доволі обмежений.
Послуги сурогатного материнства в Україні коштують від 40 до 60 тисяч євро.
У відповідь на інформаційний запит DW міністерство юстиції повідомило,
що минулого року в Україні було майже півтори тисячі таких народжень.
Утім, ця цифра не є точною, адже деякі сурогатні мами з України
їдуть народжувати за кордон.
Попит на їхні послуги останніми роками зростає, як і пропозиція.
Більшість українок народжують дітей іноземцям заради власних.
Ми з чоловіком прожили 11,5 років. Дійшли до розлучення.
Так я залишилась без нічого з двома дітьми.
В матку цій жінці імплантують ембріон з генетичного матеріалу батьків-іноземців.
За народження дитини вона отримає понад 15 тисяч євро.
І на що ви плануєте витратити ці гроші?
Насамперед на житло, гарний ремонт, а далі видно буде. Потім прийдемо і вдруге, і втретє.
Вам важко було наважитись на це?
Ні, заради власних дітей ні. Ні краплі страху.
Коли я на них дивлюсь, я хочу забезпечити їм гарне майбутнє, своє житло,
адже зараз я винаймаю квартиру.
Заради них я, не вагаючись, пішла на цей крок і ні про що не жалкую.
В більшості країн комерційне сурогатне материнство заборонене з етичних міркувань.
Зокрема, і в Німеччині.
Там передбачена кримінальна відповідальність для лікарів і адміністративна - для посередників.
Натомість генетичним батькам нічого не загрожує -
крім бюрократичної процедури "легалізації" своєї дитини.
Я буду змушена удочерити свою власну дитину.
Тому що за законами Німеччини матір'ю вважається саме та жінка, яка виносила дитину
- не має значення, чи споріднена вона з нею генетично, чи ні.
Ми сподіваємось, що сурогатне материнство нарешті буде дозволено і в Німеччині
і у нас перестануть говорити про торгівлю людьми. Адже це дурниці.
Сурогатна матір робить це від серця - тому що вона хоче допомогти іншій жінці.
Тим часом в Україні скандал із немовлятами навпаки
поновив дискусію про етичність сурогатного материнства.
Людмила Денісова, уповноважена Верховної Ради з прав людини,
спершу підтримала заборону сурогатного материнства для іноземців.
Утім, згодом вона змінила думку
і виступила лише за врегулювання ринку репродуктивних послуг.
Карантин дав нам можливість звернути увагу на сурогатне материнство,
на права дітей, права матерів, права батьків - тобто вирішити це питання в комплексі.
Безумовно, попит на сурогатне материнство для іноземців - дуже великий.
Якщо говорити так - все, забороняємо, це не вирішить питання.
Це тільки буде тіньова фабрика по народженню дітей.
Ринок репродуктивних послуг і зараз значною мірою перебуває у тіні.
Нині сурогатне материнство в Україні врегульовано
лише однією зі статей Сімейного кодексу та наказом Міністерства охорони здоров'я.
Про необхідність посилення контролю за наданням послуг сурогатного материнства
говорять навіть самі представники цього ринку.
Директор Центру медичного та репродуктивного права Сергій Антонов каже,
що такі ініціативи вже були раніше.
У нас є багато агенцій, які не мають жодного юридичного статусу - це просто хоум-офіси.
Їх ніхто не контролює, вони не сплачують податки.
Ми запропонували і механізм ліцензування такої діяльності з організації програм,
і спеціальний державний орган, який би це контролював.
А також конкретні зміни до карного і адміністративного кодексів,
щоб посилити відповідальність.
Після того, як декілька років тому ДНК-тест в Італії
не підтвердив генетичної спорідненості пари з дитиною,
яку народила українська сурогатна мама, хлопчика віддали іншій родині.
Після цього скандалу в Україні було зареєстровано кілька законопроєктів
щодо врегулювання надання послуг сурогатного материнства.
Однак жодного з них так і не ухвалили.
Тож не виключено, що після того, як немовлят,
які зараз перебувають в готелях та орендованих квартирах, заберуть їхні батьки-іноземці,
а суспільна дискусія про сурогатне материнство в Україні вщухне,
нинішні спроби врегулювати репродуктивний ринок спіткає доля попередніх ініціатив.